in the bucks systematically doing what
they have to do to can the 20-20 bucks
in place and
that was one of the other big stories
yesterday for everything the patriots
are doing to get new guys the buccaneers
doing everything they can to keep their
old guys and that's what stunned me
right out of the gates clock strikes 12.
what's the first deal we're going to
hear about what's it going to be what's
it going to be oh it's shaq barrett
where's he going where's he going
where's he going he's staying in tampa
bay yeah
with a with a four-year deal worth up to
72 million dollars that pays out 36
million guaranteed it's a 17 million per
year deal right is far from top of the
market joey boast is 27 but that's the
reality of this current market that's
where we are and that ends up being the
best offer for shaq barrett i i haven't
heard that he could have gotten more
elsewhere when drew rosenhaus announced
this deal yesterday he didn't add the
shaq barrett could have gotten more
elsewhere like he did with aaron jones
so maybe this was the best deal he could
get four years 17 million per year base
what was your immediate reaction i i
think the first thing was wow i mean the
camp the bucks are keeping everybody
unbelievable
i don't remember
a super bowl team ever
with this many free agents and like high
level ones being able to keep them
usually when we see these type of
scenarios through history and oh we won
the super bowl oh we have five or six
high level free agents you know out
there in the market we lose three of
them or we lose four out of six or five
out of seven i mean this is unreal the
the fact that they were able to keep
godwin levante david shaq barrett you
know again yeah the sign of the times
you know i think all of them being a
little bit selfless and in the fact of
maybe taking you know a hair less i
don't know about that not barrett not
barrett well that's all right so that so
one i was shocked they did it and then
two i think that was the other shocker
where you know because of what we saw
last week
and then
you know not franchise tagging him i
thought well man he must have some
offers out there where they just go
we can't compete we're not going to be
able to pay it and do it that way but
obviously it was the opposite they were
in a spot where we brought this up last
week too maybe they're in the spot where
they went hey we're in a pr we're going
to be able to afford him this this is
going to work so let's franchise godwin
just to make sure he doesn't get out of
town or something you know like that and
here they are but 36 million dollars
over two years shaq barrett yeah you'll
take that if you're the tampa bay
buccaneers i mean that's basically what
it is it's a two-year 36 million dollar
deal deal and he'll have to earn the
rest of it
two things first
the reality that they did have other
options out there in free agency if they
wanted to go there and the timing to me
says that they had an offer on the table
for shaq barrett right that was the
offer right and they told him
when noon rolls around on monday
that money we have budgeted for you is
going to go away yeah we're going to
start pursuing the other free agent pass
rushers so you have until 12. once the
clock strikes 12 we're getting on the
phone i hear this time and again and and
i know it it dehumanizes the process but
this is the way it is they got a list
they got a list and they got a phone and
they pick up the phone and they got
their list all right who's first on the
list all right here's our offer do you
want it yes or no i need to know in five
minutes all right let me know get back
to me and then move on to the next guy
if that guy says no or says anything
other than yes and i think that's what
they were going to do they had their
list of other pass rushers and if shaq
barrett didn't say yes by 12
then shaq wasn't going to get that deal
and drew rosenhaus knew because of all
the illegal tampering that happens what
else was or wasn't out there and the
other factor i think is this chris
a lot of the moves we saw yesterday if
not all of them were football moves not
business moves you're right about that
mike you'll have an owner show up and
say hey we got to spend this money
anyway we got this requirement that we
spend up to the the minimum on a
four-year rolling average and let's go
hey they won the super bowl that guy
yeah i saw him i saw him
playing in the super bowl go get him i
want him and it becomes a business move
not a football move and if it was a
business move year yeah someone would
have paid shaq barrett more than 20
million a year but it's not so he had to
take what he could get to stay in tampa
mike it's a good point you bring up
because you you're right there's not
what was the most you know
careless contract out there yesterday
you know not one jumps to mind you're
right usually in day one of free agency
you have that one or two contracts where
you go man i can't believe they paid
that guy that much money i mean it just
we didn't really get that yesterday in
fact did we get anything even
record-breaking i think joe was it joe
thuney or or toonie
was he like now was his or linsley i
thought maybe one of those i read as far
as
linsley becomes the highest paid center
in football he began
that was the two got a lot of money
right but but but they were still big
football moves no i know that's right
you're right investments you're exactly
right protecting two superstars i mean
one you know is the best player in the
league the other guy is you know
marching up the line to
to be one of the top five quarterbacks
in the league so you're right it was a
lot of chris yeah chris patoony's at 16.
laramie tunzel's at 22 and i know it's
two different positions on the offensive
line i know you could swallow that a
long way to go
from 16 to 22. yeah if you're going to
spend that money and i think that's one
of the reasons why trent williams
doesn't have a contract yet because
teams don't want to blow out the top of
the market yeah or any of these
positions yeah no it seems that way and
i mean i understand it i do there was
nothing like jaw dropping that way from
what we saw yesterday and shaq barrett i
think would be you know one of the guys
that would headline that but man just
rare to see a super bowl team stay
intact the way they have you know they
got gronk back he's there i mean they
really got everything right where they
want it or need it to make another run
we'll see what they do to kind of round
out free agency is there any you know
other guys out there
but as far as the guys we talked about
i mean i did not i don't think either
one of us thought they could keep david
barrett and godwin so they got that done
now gronk's done which we expected what
happens with sue antonio brown leonard
fournette you know we'll see i i expect
sue and brown to be back at this point i
do leonard fournette's the one guy that
i think maybe gets a little bit more
money than tampa is going to pay out on
the open market and they have ronald
jones so uh but phenomenal job by by the
the bucks organization and jason light
shireen made a good point yesterday too
when she wasn't dunking on you thank you
ryan suckup is a free agent and their
kicker position had finally been
stabilized after the roberto aguayo
misadventures you don't want him walking
away you want to find a way to keep him
as well gronk though yesterday it came
out right not long after free agency
started that he wanted to dip his his
toe in the free agency pool and see what
else was out there and people were
confused because so soon after that he
did a one-year 10 million dollar deal to
stay put well you already know that was
a taped podcast interview with kyle
brandt by the time
monday at noon rolls around you know
you've dipped your toe you know what's
out there your agents work the phones
and there isn't anything
that's better than what he was going to
get to stay with the tampa bay
buccaneers and stay with tom brady and
just maybe the willingness to see what
else was out there
got that number up a little bit to stay
in tampa bay because frankly regular
season gronk i wouldn't pay 10 million
to post season gronk i would yeah i i
hear you i think we'll see
more postseason gronk though in the
regular season next year i do i think
you know for that kind of money you know
he's had
he's he's played last year it's not like
hey let's get into shape because you
didn't play the gear before you know i
expect to see a little bit better of a
all-around quality gronk this year at
the tight end position but yeah it's the
first time we heard gronk like go off of
the i only play for tom brady for the
rest of my career now that was the first
time i ever heard comments where whoa
he'll he'll actually go somewhere else i
think we were all led to believe that
there was that possibility there was
that rumor out there
i thought miami might be a possibility
with some of those old new england
coaches that he's been with there brady
is moving there so maybe he'd figure hey
i'll meet you there in a few years
something like that uh but yep good he's
back there and wow buck's still one of
the best teams in football no doubt
about that well if he had gone to miami
he never would have been playing deep
safety on a hail mary play that never we
don't need him there
that's where that thing happened a
couple of years ago um i i'm not
convinced i i really am not convinced
we're going to see postseason gronk on a
regular basis he's going to be a year
older he's had so many injuries he the
guy just and unless it was some
elaborate season-long rope-a-dope he
just wasn't moving like he used to and
even in the super bowl it's not like it
was vintage gronk it was just better
than what we saw in the regular season i
mean that's a lot of money to pay for a
guy who blocks but you know what if
you're going to pay a tackle between 15
and 20
if your tight end is next to the tackle
and he's helping to seal that edge and
open up the running game and it's just
it's just a lot of my it's a lot of
money for gronk i was surprised he got
to eight figures well i i hear you i i
do but i think you kind of said it the
right way first off he's gronk
you know there is value in that okay but
the the the blocking is real he is like
having an extra offensive tackle
on the field with running the ball or
pass protection i mean some of the best
stuff he did last year we pointed it out
during shows during the week and stuff
was him staying in to block so brady
could feel comfortable and gash people
down the field but man he showed up at a
lot of big moments too in the past game
and of course you had the playoffs the
super bowl all that he's still a
mismatch he is and i think
you know in a year now the second year
you know one they got a ton of weapons
so they don't need to lean on them but
they'll they'll formulate i bet you a
little bit more of a package here now
that you'll have an off season stuff too
to where they'll have a more you know
base group of plays they can go to and
all that at the very least
he is his size is still real i mean
that's the big thing if you talk to
coaches over the years who played gronk
the first thing they always go is just
man we just weren't prepared for how big
he was we just we didn't realize we knew
he was a pretty good athlete we didn't
realize how big he was i mean even when
we covered him we couldn't cover him and
that's the type of thing he does he is a
true mismatch in the past game still
even though you know to your point he
doesn't move the way he used to
and we know how tom brady feels about
him when brady does a new contract and
an extension that doesn't increase his
25 million per year rate which is a hell
of a bargain when you consider what he's
brought to that franchise and he creates
19.3 million in cap space and he wants
gronk on the team that helps gronk make
a little extra money yeah and that may
have been the difference to get the deal
done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports